or you know the Black Widow she mates
with her her male mate and then she
stuffs them so I'm working on this
estrogen thing heavy it's gonna be part
of that Geiger counter thing I okay
embarrassment I'm 56 years old and I'm a
virgin it's not gone off but testimony
should be relevant to the item before
mr. car you remember when you vote it
and you can answer this after I sit down
three minutes some folks a little lost
in town don't have a lot of dough
they're not using all your gasoline they
like to go real slow my legal name is
Greg gay I was bullied I had my head
shoved in the urinal Lance you the one
that shoved my head in the middle thank
you
bitches ain't but hoes and tricks
look on these nuts and a sexually active
person I do no sex there's a movie
called
ARR Ohio 2014 get up and watch it and
guess what I'm not the rancher not the
ranchers wife stop the ranchers kid not
that I couldn't have been that's not the
path I chose was it my ex-husband's the
killer and news flash she's not dead I
have two boobs not six six bucks because
when you guys are talking about me you
have no idea who knows me sane people
know that showing up at the local City
Council meetings will accomplish nothing
that's why I asked you to send me any
complaints about your community and I
will give them the national platform
they don't deserve in a segment I'm
calling local twizz
first in my town of Glen Cove my
neighbors believe that they own the
street so they put out cones to reserved
parking spots one neighbor in particular
doesn't like his cones touch so he goes
off whenever someone moves his cone or
his recycling bin he uses as a third
comon oh I recommend settling this with
violence
the Steak and Shake in Cape Girardeau
Missouri closed at 10:00 p.m. that's too
early please help us
Tucker I hear you but you really
shouldn't be eating steaks or shakes
after 10:00 p.m. now if you have to buy
heat lamp and pick up your food at 10:00
and keep it warm until you're hungry my
city Clayton Missouri band golf carts on
the street I've been driving my golf
cart on the street for years the
surrounding cities allow it but I just
driving illegally to get out of Clayton
helped me okay the here's what your new
buddy Gary golf ball with you at all
times then when you get pulled over you
tell those do-nothing sons of bitches
running Clayton hey you're playing your
ball where it lies there's no Wi-Fi in
my high school and they make us use our
phones for a bunch of things wasting
data I can't afford also they opened up
a second cafeteria in recent renovations
called the internet cafe but they don't
allow student I gotta go I bye
you better be careful right with all
caps they don't put you on a list I'm
tired of these spandex wearing cycle
freaks parading around in their bicycle
gangs slowing down traffic in Gwinnett
County Georgia we need to introduce
lions to the local population - Cole
this Lance Armstrong herd I like where
your head's at I've fully endorsed
releasing Lions in the streets of
Georgia I'm just surrounded by idiots
kalkaska Michigan well sure you are you
live in Kalkaska the principal tore a
high school in Wisconsin has slept with
multiple faculty members and even had a
pregnancy scare with one of them and no
I'm not talking about his wife who is
also a faculty member of the same high
school
all right you Little Snitch
you mind your own goddamn business and
let adults do what adults do tell travel
magazine to stop naming Charleston the
number one city in the country it's
driving all the Ohioans here you'd have
to live in Ohio your entire life to
believe Charleston is the number one
city anywhere
okay what is this Beverly Hills no this
is Charleston South Carolina this looks
just like Malibu no Charleston is this
South Beach Miami no it's Charleston is
this New York City oh look at all this
energy noise Charleston South Carolina
hey is this the Windy City I just such a
great food no no you're in Charleston
Charleston South Carolina
how many others say I could Austin is
this Austin so much culture so much good
music no no this is Charleston South
Carolina you can tell because we still
have one of our old slave auction blocks
I don't think I'm far off
Vandalia Ohio there are no sidewalks
connected to the middle school for kids
that's probably for the best we could
stand to have a few less middle
schoolers same-sex couples can't go to
prom together
commerce Oklahoma you guys got one of
those boring ass sis hat proms
you should at least be allowed to use
the backdoor you get it Sherwin Williams
has dumped toxic waste from their pain
and gibbsboro New Jersey and now it's
causing a lot of health issues for the
residents it's classified as a cancer
cluster and the residents have mental
health issues the land water and air are
toxic this sounds like it might be more
of a Netflix Nakia is kind of problem we
need to dam Popeyes Chicken and
Stillwater Oklahoma do the Lord's work
Daniel bring me some of that finger
lickin good news okay first of all
finger licking good is cassia confused
okey I live in Maplewood Minnesota and
it's shaped like a bunch of cities were
glued together it sure is I am all for
redrawing all city lines until
everything looks like a perfect square
hashtag square Eman during our
neighborhood has a sewer problem in
Orange Texas it's the Nottingham
neighborhood off of highway 87 the
slightest rain and nobody can flush help
us fix this please you sure it's not all
those Husky brisket dumps you guys are
famous for war work Pennsylvania our
school district still doesn't offer
full-day kindergarten but somehow
expects children to walk in the first
grade being able to read forces working
parents to have to pay for private
daycare most of other surrounding
districts already offer full-day
kindergarten okay let me tell you
something how dare they make you spend
more time with your shitty illiterate
children
who needs kindergarten in Pennsylvania
anyway you're just gonna end up working
in a coal mine Kalamazoo Michigan pair
of shitty panties water bottle and a
pack of Newports on the corner of our
busiest road been there for weeks you
sure it's not a roadside memorial for
some lot lizard pay your respects just
to be safe then pick it up sometimes my
fish tacos aren't hot enough Honolulu
Hawaii Mahalo for your patience Hawaii
go outside hold it over your lava for 30
seconds you'll have all the heat you can
handle twitter has ruined America